good evening everybody and welcome to
our last 15k workshop before semifinal
judging
we're going to talk about using data to
tell your story
to benchmark and to communicate your
failures and successes in your venture
as you look at your market you look at
your investors and you
have sort of keep moving through with
your growth mentality so
theo and i are gonna sort of trade back
and forth
it can be very conversational feel free
to ask us questions
during the presentation we'll also be
leaving time for some questions at the
end but
this is definitely meant to be
informative but conversational
so here we go
what have i done i'm off to a great
start
okay so we are talking about
storytelling through data in
your venture
and what are we doing here you're gonna
have people who give you a lot of money
ideally
um if all goes according to plan and
they're gonna want to know what you've
been
doing with their money so um the best
way of telling your story is through a
mix of qualitative
and quantitative data um it's really
common
in fundraising in lots of different
things to give
reports to your funders to your granters
so
keeping a sort of fact-finding mentality
as you look at every aspect of your
venture is going to be really important
in how you communicate because um
you want to be honest about what doesn't
work you want to be
agile in your responses to those sorts
of things and you want to look at what
you've got to continue to grow and
iterate
so um it's all about telling a really
compelling
story now i'm trying to keep it pretty
broad tonight your mileage is going to
vary
because some of you are in software some
of you are in hardware
some people will be for-profits some
people will be non-profits
the core concept remains the same um
so we'll do some broad strokes theo and
i will get into some
more specifics that diverge things that
are more qualitative things that are
more quantitative but basically
evaluation is not a one-size-fits-all
kind of thing
what's good for your venture might not
be good for somebody else's
it's about finding that creativity and
keeping that sort of
um storytelling mindset a for-profit
will tell a different story from a
non-profit because the latter
is much more mission driven and service
driven as opposed to bottom line driven
um if you're in a startup you're going
to have so many more things to measure
um in some ways and if you're very
advanced you're going to have a track
record that you know you can look back
to
as you continue to build and develop but
um we're also going to get into
something later
about your market who are you serving
what are the best metrics for your field
they're not all going to overlap neatly
so
as we move on um we're gonna go through
talking through your pitch through your
meetings with people through your
stakeholder conversations so
starting with data in your pitch take it
away theo
theo's muted i like i i
apologize for uh staying on mute there i
uh misclicked um
yes i think just to talk broadly about
like what data does
or doesn't do so i think the main thing
is
you know there's a compelling message
and compelling story and data can't
be the entire story or data is not
everything that you want to talk about
but it is
really important and i think it also
gets you a lot more
memorability and specificity and so if
you think about what
sticks in someone's mind when you talk
about a specific like let's say it's 100
billion dollar market
that's different than saying the
market's really large and so
talking about the there's definitely the
problem but then once you get to kind of
the
the value of solving that problem and
being as specific as you can there
really helps for someone who's an
investor or
in this competition a judge someone to
really understand kind of what
what the importance of your solution is
and so that kind of gets at the the so
what
question i think it helps to give
something that you are talking about in
order of magnitude
and to talk about the really specific
value of what you're trying to do
um and then going back to bullet point
number two for a second so talk about
your
what the what's your market question uh
this is definitely an important one to
think about
um both for the competition but then
more broadly for your venture
um as something that investors will look
at or evaluate
really like one of the main questions is
always going to be tam or total
addressable market
and so as much as you can even though
you may believe that if something is
really large right like let's say if
you're working on something
you know healthcare related people spend
lots of money on health care health care
is a huge market
that's great but instead if you have a
very specific number i'm
looking at this specific type of patient
with this specific type of disease
there are 40 000 of those people in the
united states and they pay
100 000 a year for treatment and that's
my market like that's a much more
specific
and quantifiable and memorable thing and
so that's kind of the importance there
um and then just talking more broadly
this
is something that i would definitely
look to incorporate into
your semi-final presentation if you
haven't already um
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
these exact metrics but just something
to be thinking about so
in terms of there's different kinds of
of startups and different kinds of
metrics that are really important
uh one thing that's important for
everyone is that kind of the
the break-even point so at what size do
we start to envision becoming profitable
how much are we going to be spending
before then so think about like what's
your your cash outflows
uh what's the value of a customer was it
cost
to get that customer and then kind of
like roughly what those ratios are is
like how much
how much more are we getting in lifetime
value than we're spending to bring
someone in
the door uh and then we won't go through
these in particular but
i think especially if you're coming back
to look at this as a recording
or we can actually share probably this
deck afterwards but we did notice that
there were
um a number of marketplace and hardware
related ventures and so these are just
some important
data points and i don't think that like
this is not a checklist
that you have to complete to have a good
application that's not
that i guess what i'm trying to say but
more more these are the kinds of things
that really make your point
and your your goals much more specific
and much more compelling uh similar to
how it's just a little more memorable
with a quantitative number i think even
at an estimated value
for these things just shows a level of
intentionality and
and sophistication so definitely good to
have these if you can
perfect so now
value feeds right into that and theo's
gonna take this again
too it's more specifics about you know
conveying all of these really important
things i don't know what i just said
take it away for you yeah i think um
the thing i would say so like one of the
first things to think about
is product market fit or traction and so
there are different ways to kind of show
that
the your idea has something behind it
right and so i guess
there's different ways to communicate
this but really all you're looking for
is the idea that there's just such a
there's like a burning need for this
and so the few ways to kind of go about
demonstrating that is talking about you
know
like organic customer discovery and so
people are just looking for
your solution and just find you and sign
up so people that you're not advertising
to
people who aren't referrals people who
you're not
paying to reach but people who who kind
of come in and find you
a second thing that if you already have
customers who
are either paying customers or pilot
customers or somehow
involved right um this is actually a
pretty
a pretty interesting test uh that we get
advice to use in some of the product
management courses over at sloan
uh and the question is how would you
feel if you could no longer use whatever
the product or service is and you have
to ask
customers and basically if we were no
longer for sale would you be
very disappointed somewhat disappointed
or would you not really care
um and as a general rule you you want
about
40 of customers to be saying very
disappointed
at around 40 that's when you know that
you've got
a pretty strong amount of product market
fit um and so that
that's just another way to gauge and of
course not everyone will be there
immediately but it's just something to
keep in mind and
the the underlying point which is that
the customers really want the solution
and
they'd be sad if we took it away like
that's an important part to kind of be
thinking about or talking about
then the other the last point here is on
uh willingness to pay and so this is an
interesting thing and it's a little bit
hard to
to test especially if you are um looking
at something that you don't necessarily
have a product yet or you don't
necessarily have paying customers yet
and so you can't say this is the
specific price point that i think we
should charge or this is the specific
amount of value
that i think a customer would receive
but there is a kind of there are
definitely as always creative solutions
here
and so if you think about this think
about what your solution is
how are people paying today right and it
could be something that people are
paying directly for it
they could be you know spending money on
something like
art supplies through amazon or
uh they could be paying with their time
and so it could be something like a
customer is going and spending
a lot of time on you know blick.com or
somewhere else
looking at all these different art
supplies and how much time are they
spending how much
extra effort and energy are they
spending and so think about that
that time and then you can think about
how does that customer value their time
and so like let's say if it's someone
who's you know really
busy very has a lot of disposable income
but like is works constantly they may
value their time really highly
and so in a way that you can kind of
quantify okay someone who makes fifty
dollars an hour
is spending eight hours a week doing
this thing
now i i can kind of quantify that's what
they're paying
today and uh typically you can think
about this as a loose
metric or a loose idea but whatever
value you're saving
for your customer either in terms of
cost or time you can usually capture
about one tenth of that
and so in that example of someone who's
making 50 an hour eight hours a week i
think i said
so that is what four hundred dollars a
week
so reasonably like if you can deliver
something to them for forty dollars that
saves them that time
they will want to do it and so that's
just kind of a
loose way to kind of get at willingness
to pay and value and things like that
but but more than anything else i think
the takeaway here is
try to quantify this the best you can
and even if it's not
not perfect even if it's not scientific
or statistically significant or anything
like that
i think again just kind of the the fact
that you're doing that kind of
validation and doing that kind of
of work and really know your customers
well enough to
to have that kind of detailed insight
into your problem and solution
is really what's what's valuable about
this
all right so
assessing the status quo you've all got
a startup sort of venture you're at
various different places
and the really um elemental thing
after communicating all of these really
cool data points in your pitch
now you've got to look at your venture
and what have you got going for you you
kind of have to start
like a laundry list it can be holistic
it can be specific but
look how many full-time equivalent
employees
do you have who are you employing how
can you pay them are you paying them in
kind
is this a sweat equity kind of thing do
you have budget
what kinds of in-kind assets do you have
um
a performing ensemble might not have an
awful lot going for it but if you've got
a core roster and you're paying people
and you've got access to a performance
or recording space
that's something you've got going for
you or if you're beta testing something
you've got you know durable goods and
you've got prototypes you've got
um you know you can start building
testimonials
you can have your aspirations you can
have a loyal customer base
before you even get to finances there
are so many things that are
very storytelling and data rich that you
can look at
if you just sort of take inventory of
everything you've got going for you so
um yeah it boils down to
what are people going to want to listen
to how will this be memorable
how will this be something that you can
convey to people that
show that you're on a positive
trajectory and get them interested in
you
theo yes yes and the next part is about
kind of the
the forward-looking piece and so
thinking about what you
how you think your business will grow
and so i think
there are um you know it's tempting
always to
really look at like companies that are
you know you kind of you can say like a
rocket ship where they really took off
and grew
really rapidly um and and try to
basically
see like apply those same numbers or try
to
assume that your your venture will grow
exponentially really quickly
um and i think that while that's a
obviously you want to be ambitious and
have an optimistic outlook
at the same time i think there are there
are important things to think about and
especially once you start to bring on
either co-founders or employees or
investors they'll kind of rely on you um
to be
you know the voice of reasonable growth
here um and so you think about
first thing i'll talk about is like
what's kind of my pipeline and so
if you think about you want to grow in
the next month you want to take on
three or four new customers that
actually probably means that you need to
be talking to
a group of maybe 10 or maybe 20
potential leads
and so if you think about it's important
to kind of understand that relationship
and also think about what am i
projecting
or saying is going to happen and if you
don't have to have a clear idea of like
what your pipeline looks like
um then you maybe don't want to estimate
or or kind of
plan or build for this huge amount of
growth without kind of an idea where
it's coming from
and realistically like there's a
kind of a saying and at least like sales
and it is definitely true i think
entrepreneurial sales as well
whatever you think your pipeline is you
should cut it in half
and then cut that in half and so
reasonably like
it's probably about one quarter of of
what you think is going to happen will
actually come through
because stuff just doesn't work out for
for different reasons
um an important thing also to be
thinking about is is what changes
as you grow and so if you think about
the amount of time
and effort that you're spending on
things that
as that scales up what will happen
one second i think um if my headphones
die i'll try to just keep talking
let me know if if my uh voice
or uh audio sounds very weird um
yeah and so like as you grow as you
scale up you know your time as like a
founder or founding team
is very limited what will have to change
do you bring on more people do you start
to find ways to try to save time or save
costs or save energy
i mean it's important to think about
that and then the last thing i'll say
that is
i think very underestimated undervalued
is
that like um as you grow and acquire
bring on more customers you actually for
a while have negative value
right and so when you bring on a new
customer there is a time when you
provide
a service or you provide something to
them
but you haven't yet gotten your money
back so as an example let's say i sign
up for twitter
i have to create an account there's cost
associated with
hosting my content and all that kind of
stuff
um but until i see like a certain number
of ads
i'm still a a negative financial value
for them right until i reach a certain
point
i am still in the red they've paid for
me to be
on the platform but i'm not yet uh
breaking even and so if you do this same
kind of calculation and you think about
now okay we got a hundred customers a
thousand customers ten thousand and you
think about like you wanna grow really
rapidly
you have the same effect the same kind
of green area where
it's negative times ten thousand right
this is a hugely compounding effect and
so just something to think about when
you're projecting growth
is how how much of this kind of negative
how much of this churn or spend can we
afford before we start to break even on
customers
and when will we run out of money
because we need to
kind of keep those things balanced
um excuse me
so check your plan there
is a lot to be said you know theo was
just talking about
um being able to project being able to
look at that and it can feel like it's
all happening kind of in a vacuum
so um theo what are your recommendations
for this
yeah i would say that like where you can
look at comparable businesses
and then especially i think if you
have sorry for the uh the background
noise here by the way
um so if you have a comparable startup
the best thing that you can do is find
startup mentors find people who are in
relevant spaces
um talk to people who have been on on a
similar entrepreneurial journey and have
been at the different stages that you're
probably going to be at
uh and so depending on what your your
venture is
it doesn't have to be exactly the same
but i think if you are
looking at something that's like
consumer facing b2c software
look for entrepreneurs or mentors in
that space and they can help you with
where they kind of what what their
numbers
what their costs things like that looked
like
um and if you are something like an
apparel company um
you should look for other apparel
companies and try to find those other
other
mentors that people have been in in that
spot before
now that's not always possible to do
it's not always easy to do people aren't
always
super forthcoming with their their own
data and information as well
and also that takes time right so you
have to go out and develop those
relationships find those people
um a fast and easy shortcut
in in some ways but also it's not quite
as good quality is looking at
uh different sources of publicly
available information
so as an example we have nike here um
and
as a uh their their gross margins are
typically around 47 or 48
and so i know that if i'm starting a
shoe or shoe related company
reasonably like that's probably the best
i could do
in the short term right i don't have the
same production scales and i get on the
same brand as nike i don't have any of
those same things
and so if i have like that that metric
is probably
even better than i could hope for but at
least i kind of know
i'm not planning on you know 80 or 90
um and if you say well you know maybe i
sell fancy shoes maybe i have
you know more of a luxury uh footwear or
a brand
these nikes here i just picked as an
example because they're like 5 000 or 10
thousand dollars like these are super
expensive super fancy ones
um you know i know sharers i saw that
reaction they're called the yellow
lobster
nikes um i don't really know i mean i
guess i can kind of see it
when you look at them um but but yeah
so like even even then right even if
your luxury or your fancy apparel
you know in some ways so are they and so
um
just try to find something relevant and
publicly available and that can at least
help guide you
and that's kind of a short answer
and then i advanced the slide perfect
timing love when that works
so in addition to looking at
you know comparable organizations for
business plans
you also want to hit this market and you
want people to trust you
you want people to pick you and
testimonials are really helpful
qualitative data i think people get
really caught up in hard numbers they
tell a story themselves
but you know there are certain
intangible things that make us all
really excited about our favorite brand
of footwear favorite brand of
like ketchup even you know some of this
is because of very qualitative
intangible values so um if you can get
information from your users and
from your own venture you know survey
people look at social media look at
testimonials
because um i've sort of
semi-coined quantitative because you can
take things like number of five-star
reviews
and that's some hard numbers um averages
things like that
but it's all really important we all
read the reviews
i i do anyway i read consumer reports
if i'm trying to buy a new microplane
zester i'm still gonna go and look and
see what people have to say about it
so getting rave reviews getting
good qualitative support underpins
a really good storytelling narrative
that you can employ when you're pitching
or when you're talking with potential
customers or when you're talking with
your funders your investors so i've got
some examples
of how to build your story this one's
interesting it will be happier i promise
but you know there was a situation a
couple of years ago
where 34 miniature horses were in
quite poor health and they needed to be
re-homed
so the mspca local animal rights
organizations banded together
so somebody who works here said that it
was one of the saddest
rescues they had experienced in quite a
while there were so many animals they
were in such desperate condition
now this is a really good hook it's a
dreadful story but we want to see how it
turns out
so you know we've had our discord but
fortunately we have a solution the
animal rescue league arrived in time to
remove the horses from these deplorable
conditions and begin the treatment that
they'll need
as we ready them for their new lives
okay
we know that this is going to end well
for the horses but what happens how do
we communicate the particulars of this
situation
so if you look at it we have data we
have the number of horses in their
destinations if we were reporting to
somebody
about what happened we would have to say
18 of them went to nevin's
16 went to the animal rescue league if
we win if we want to tell a story about
our budget
we talk about how it cost about a
thousand dollars per horse for the
ongoing treatments that they needed that
was food
shelter deworming from parasites things
like that
um you know you can measure their
improvement are they healthier are they
gaining weight are they happier are they
eating more are they dewormed
like some of these are quant some of
these are qual
you want to keep this story fresh you
want to keep the public apprised of the
adoption
statuses and there are numbers in that
so really just pick apart every level of
the story and what you can communicate
as something that was a tangible and
actionable item
and this story i mean nobody likes
hearing about
you know malnourished animals but what
they
did to handle this situation will also
help to build a scaffold and inform how
they'll respond to similar situations in
the future
so if you know how you can rehabilitate
them how much it costs where they can go
quantify how many of these animals that
you saved
people are going to start trusting you
you're going to have a good reputation
so you know there are google reviews
they they save pigs they save a lot of
other kinds of animals and people are
saying it's the most
wonderful animal shelter you could ever
go to or the best experience i've ever
had i would recommend to all
so if you sort of jumble up the quant
and the qual elements of this
you've got a very mission driven
organization the mspca they have
fulfilled their mission and they've told
a story we had 34 horses who came to us
in pretty bad
shape and you know you identify
each of the storytelling elements that
make it really compelling
you figure out where the communicable
outcomes are
and then you build loyalty i mean
if i ever had to adopt a pet i'd
probably go to nevin's farms
mspca like you know these testimonials
matter and their fulfillment of their
mission and their communication of their
success are all really sound structural
underpinnings to be able to demonstrate
success
so further expressing outcomes
look at past documentation look at your
prior benchmarks
what did you say that you were going to
do did you do it
how did you do it did you exceed your
goals that's great
if you didn't why not and what else is
compelling
basically how can these outcomes build a
platform for your continued growth and
benchmarking because
you know we can't rest on our laurels
you've always got to be sort of building
and iterating and looking at the next
opportunities so
looking at sort of a logic model kind of
approach
you look at your inputs you look at all
the steps you need to take
you look at your outputs and then your
outcomes um
and that will sort of keep you honest
it'll keep you telling your story it
will keep you
able to build and iterate and grow and
develop
so this also leads to
really cold analysis of
how you communicate using data your
successes
and your failures you gotta keep your
butt covered and you
have to be willing to own your
shortcomings
make contingency plans for things make
sure
that you aren't shooting for the moon
you don't want to say that you're going
to make a billion dollars in your first
year
be a little conservative in your growth
and also be really
self-aware and analytical in a way that
will help you
to preserve a growth mentality because
it's not always going to be easy it's
not always going to be fun and you're
not going to do everything right
but that's okay that's how you learn but
that's also not a sexy way to approach
an investor or your market
so keep your growth mentality and keep
your swagger
you know diagnose what happened why is
it happening
what does it mean moving forward um it's
really common
um as we noted for early companies to
underperform
or they might over perform really wildly
versus what they set out and said that
they would do
but you know the upshot here is that
you've got to set
a new best possible plan using all of
the information that you now have at
your disposal
i mean any measurable outcome
any data good to have will help you with
your road mapping for the future
so i've got an example um we were
talking about
some more numbers driven things earlier
this is going to be
um about how you communicate when things
don't go exactly according to plan
the handle and haydn society is a period
instrument orchestra
it's the oldest continually operating
arts nonprofit in the united states
and they have a really robust education
and community engagement program
as part of their um mission
not just to perform really good concerts
but also to give back to the community
get more people interested in
the arts so they have
these public school programs they go
into
underprivileged public schools that
don't have music teachers and are not
getting the
required recommended uh or
suggested amounts of arts education per
the massachusetts state frameworks
curriculum
so they go and bring resources to
underperforming schools that don't have
the necessary
faculty to cover these areas and
they really wanted to make sure that
they were not just catering to
you know affluent primarily white
caucasian
markets here so they're going in and
they wanted to expand the number of
bypass students that they served
they didn't meet this benchmark there
was some funding that didn't come
through
there was a school partnership that fell
through because
of a transition with a principal um
there were certain things that weren't
really in the cards
but there were other ways that they
could tell their story
they could sort of flip the narrative
because what ended up happening is that
without being able to expand the number
of students that
were served they were able to funnel
their resources more
in a more concentrated way to their
existing partnerships so
rather than expanding they were able to
deepen their impact they were able to
give
you know three hours per week of
education instead of
one or two they were able to hit more
students
within individual schools instead of
expanding the number of schools
so at the end of the day they didn't
meet this particular benchmark
but the way that they communicated their
success
was basically discussing how much more
in depth they were able to um
teach engage in still appreciation in
and
you know meet curricular benchmarks with
a more concentrated group so
um always figure out what you can talk
about
you know it's it's not misleading if you
screw up if you miss a goal but
something else goes really well
then like cling to that make sure that
you know how not to replicate the
mistake that you made
but you know keep telling the good story
um
so sort of takeaways before we move into
some questions
measure everything look at what you've
got
you know like you're trying to sell it
to people
you know look at your assets look at
your opportunities
and measure things that don't even seem
like they will be
statistically significant because you
never know how things will interact
um just find new ways of gauging
everything because everything is good
you want to build your story as robustly
as possible and then trim it down you
don't want to be left scrambling trying
to
fluff things up like you're writing a
paper an hour before it's due um
look at how you can accomplish your
goals in a way that will be
immediately and intuitively communicable
to somebody on the outside that could be
a consumer
that could be a funder but you know
having infographics having
easy ways of communicating things having
a really great
story having an amazing testimonial or
review
um you can know how well you're doing
sort of backstage
back ops but you need everybody to be
able to know quickly in a digestible way
why you rock and why this venture is
thriving
so you know there will be moments when
it's less thriving so when your plans
change and when you're thrown a
curveball
keep being agile be really creative and
be responsive
to opportunities for clever problem
solving you know h didn't
get their benchmark but you know they
were able to offer something else
instead as an
indicator of the efficacy of their
programming um
and when you're setting goals make sure
that
you're sort of keeping a mind towards
storytelling
toward data expression because you
this will facilitate other outcomes that
you can emphasize again
if things don't go according to plan and
like
just keep telling an awesome story is
sort of my
upshot theo do you have any other things
in closing to add
no i think um we can we could probably
go on the q a and then
um one last thing i'll say on this point
is that like there's definitely lots of
positive and negative examples
there's one thing that's really top of
mind for me actually with some of the
work that i've been doing
um with uh you know it's actually a
group of investors and it's a venture
capital firm
one of their companies they were looking
at
raising more money they barely missed
they had a projection of revenue for
q1 of 2021 that they barely missed
um and actually i don't think it was so
much they missed but they just didn't
have a good explanation they didn't have
a good story
and they weren't exactly sure why it
happened so they kind of came up with
like
well maybe it was this maybe it's that
we're not super sure
and that actually caused the investor to
delay and so right now they're actually
looking at how do we get more funding
what do we do now
and so like obviously i think that's a
negative example and there's obviously
positive examples as well
but that's something to think about it's
just kind of like again it's not
it's not so much i mean the data itself
always definitely matters and
at a place like mit i think we have to
all you know agree to that
but um the is more kind of like the
the story and understanding the the
relationships between
the data and your business and kind of
like the root causes behind
some of these things and so that's
that's i think what's most important and
definitely the
key takeaway from tonight that was
really well put
and i think that's you know it can feel
intangible and i know that we weren't
able to
get as specific with all of you about
your ventures in particular but i hope
that this was a helpful
sort of broad overview and narrative
because
you know like theo said you got to be
able to back it up
otherwise the money might go away and
you know
you want everybody to recognize you to
recognize you as successful to want to
be on board
buying your product engaging in your
services
funding you to do it so yeah just always
be ready
always be thinking about growth and
always think about how you can measure
all of this
and with that i'm going to stop my
screen share
and see if anybody has any questions or
conversation points
we're also available via email in case
anything comes up
that you um are not thinking of right
now or would rather
you know if you've got some place to be
you know you can always hit us up
yeah exactly as you're working through
your applications do you have any things
where
you feel like there should be a data
point here but i'm not sure how to get
there
how to address it um we'd be happy to
try to also
help you work through something like
that so definitely feel free to reach
out
absolutely um if there are no questions
oh good yeah yeah yeah
awesome presentation first of all thank
you i thanks higher informative uh one
question i have
is i guess the uncertainty uh and a lot
of numbers and data there's like
a sense of like especially as an
engineer uh with engineering background
like uncertainty is very important when
you're doing something physical
so when you're doing projection etc how
much emphasis should you put on like
uncertainty of your
calculation or measurement
i think that there is a sort
of sweet spot where you have to stay
confident so people trust you but you
have to stay
receptive to the idea that it's not
going to work and i think being
ambitious finding the line of ambition
with conservatism
is it's a sort of difficult concept to
pinpoint because you don't want to low
ball yourself
and you don't want to suggest that
you're not going to grow but again you
can't just go
screaming out of the gates saying we're
gonna make a billion dollars next year
so i think that having composure and
confidence
in what you know that you can deliver
with
that sort of measure of humility i would
also say not to be shy about the
uncertainty i think that if you manage
people's expectations up front and say
here's how our choices were informed
you know this is how we're going to go
on from there
i think people are comfortable having
those conversations
like theo just said if you don't have an
explanation
for why things worked or why things
didn't work
you're not gonna get consumer confidence
and you're not gonna be able to build or
grow if you're just flinging things at
the wall to see what sticks
then you know i guess don't be uncertain
silly advice but um you know there there
will be things that go well there will
be things that don't go well
so you know i think that if you've got
a robust infrastructure that is data
driven
and outcome driven then you'll have a
really good idea
and as you continue to develop your
confidence in that will work
and more to that point there are plenty
of places that got completely
comprehensively hosed by kovid something
might
come out of the woodwork that is
completely unexpected
and in that case having contingency
plans and being able to
still talk about how you succeeded is
you know
an important thing um you know were you
still able to compensate your employees
did you keep
people working during the pandemic were
you able to shift to some other form of
content consumption
like there will be uncertainty but
always be ready kind of to talk about
how awesome you are
okay life just threw me this curveball
everything is a disaster
look at how we're flipping this to our
advantage just create opportunities
wherever you can and that will help to
mitigate some of the uncertainty
if you've got that sort of exploratory
minded
perspective about it then if you go off
script a little bit it's
like very forgivable
thank you cool anything to add theo
anybody else
it can be a conversation too if anybody
has questions or input you know this is
this is the democratic part yeah um i
actually wanted to ask uh
how is it in the in like the arts
community uh would you say
um it like it's it's similar to like
startup
culture in a way that they they also
have this
like very scrappy kind of like failure
is what we want culture or is more like
you know a bit more conscious about you
know
how they're doing things a bit more
conventional um
how like how is the art community going
over
what you are addressing it's really
interesting because in some ways like an
under-resourced arts non-profit
never leaves scrappy startup mentality
phase
but that is really all about outcomes
because if you're working on a
shoestring
budget um you've got
to convey how you're delivering because
in that kind of situation
some of your revenue will be from
program services
if you're in a performing arts
non-profit you will sell a certain
number of tickets
but the majority of your income is
coming at the whim
of others that could be whether or not
you were successful
soliciting major donations or an annual
appeal campaign
you're kind of shaking the couch for
loose change
in some cases because every 10 000
donor and every 10 donor they all matter
you could be writing grants you could be
you know
basically you've got to be able to talk
about and substantiate
your awesomeness because your existence
is at the whim of people deciding to
support you and
part with their money so if anything
as as challenging as the arts can be
as a field they have to be like
wizards of expressing outcomes i learned
an awful lot about data collection
when i worked as a grant writer for some
arts nonprofits because
those are serious financial institutions
and foundations
that are parting with their resources
and
they want to know how that money is
being spent so you've got to know
there were 83 children in the youth
chorus or
at this concert at symphony hall it was
a sellout and that means
x number of thousands of people um
you've really got to be pretty
mechanical about talking about something
that is
largely so difficult and intangible to
measure
because you know that's what keeps
people
opening their wallets so i think that as
challenging as it is to project growth
and to facilitate growth in a lean
non-profit mentality
as far as storytelling and data and
expressing outcomes are concerned
that scrappy mentality really serves
that sector
very well because like it or not you're
continuing to justify
your existence on a daily basis so if
you have that mentality
maybe under a little bit less duress
that's a really good way to move
forward just you know assert your
awesomeness
and and consider that you're basically
justifying your existence
and backing it up with these really
awesome outcomes
yeah i think that's very well said and
also something that we're seeing at 25
um like we've got all of those crazy
ideas like popping up in our minds
all day long you know things that we
that we potentially
could do um but then what we're seeing
is
when whenever we are talking to to our
stakeholders or like people like you
uh we we cannot go out there and be like
oh like just today we had this awesome
crazy idea that we want to try
like this is not how it works we we we
must kind of stick to our narrative
yeah right and um and and make and
justify the whole thing
exactly what you're saying and that can
be hard right because if you've also got
all of these aspirations you know you
want to make sure
that you are communicating everything
that you're doing effectively
and you want to make sure that you're
going to be able to
accomplish these things so having that
storytelling mentality is great and
having
a place to go if you've got an ambition
and a trajectory that's great but like
conversationally presenting some of
these really creative ideas before you
have any outcomes to back them
is what's going to turn a potential
supporter off they don't want to know
what these really cool ideas are um
until you can prove that you're going to
make them happen and that it's worth
their time
and money yeah i think that makes no
sense i i would say uh a vast like
like like this one idea that we have you
know kind of like snap it get it i mean
that's what we are about that's what we
are bidding
like that that is already enough to like
get them excited you know and get them
going and um
and we really learned like i say what
you're saying that like focusing is
really much more about
not being distracted about things that
do not really matter
rather than trying out everything we can
get our hands on and
doing a mediocre job um on all of those
things you know whatever specialize on
one
and get that going hard enough already
as a takeaway because
it's it's hard to see sort of the forest
for the trees too when you're close to
this and when you are so
committed to it a lot of this sort of
intrinsically makes sense to you
you're always thinking about how you
want to succeed
but that internal ambition also needs to
be externalized in ways that make a lot
of sense to people who are
less familiar with this and you know
it's awesome to have 10 really great
ideas in your own personal pipeline but
until you know
how to communicate how effective they're
going to be like
they're not ready for prime time
yeah very much feeling that yeah
and that's cool though because the more
data you can gather the more success
that you can demonstrate
then you get to start ramping up to
these ambitions and you say
based on our past history of this this
new thing this new idea this new feature
is you know likely to succeed
come on and help us like it
it leaves a lot of room so you know if
you're doing a good job with your
benchmarking and with your
data collection and proving yourself
then
people will also be excited you know
once you establish that track record
you know and you're not susceptible to
crazy anomalies
you know you'll know what people like
you'll know what people want
and then you can use that to inform how
you continue to build toward those other
dreams
oh yeah yeah that is very very well said
i mean we're seeing that
like every day uh reaching out to you
know major fashion brands um
like the number one reason for for them
rejecting us is literally like
okay so we what we are seeing is you're
you're kind of ambitious kids at mit
you're building something that could
potentially be great
but what's your track record right like
you you've never done something like
that before
um you know what's like how can we be
reassured
that it's actually gonna create us
returns right
and um yeah i think i think also this
this competition is a great way to
to to build a track record in a sense um
a connect with people
kind of um really practice getting your
narrative out there
became a huge disalignments uh it's also
what we've been seeing right and just
being out there and talking to people
just like you just like our participants
um
was was a great experience and it's it's
it's much undervalued
um much much unappreciated
when it comes to building your own thing
i think well that just made my night
i mean we're really happy to be here and
we're hopeful that
this will help people's track records
just being able to
convey some of these things you know in
the fundraising world they say that
gifts we get
gifts grants beget grants your project
will become more attractive to people
when
they see that others have taken the risk
or decided to invest or
feel that the outcome is
probable enough that they want to be
part of it so you know
being able to demonstrate those things
should poise you pretty well moving
forward
i mean it's i think something that is
a little neglected in these
conversations so i'm really glad that
we've sort of got that value added
in how we've structured this competition
but i think that
you know whether you get to the finals
whether you win or not
ideally having been through this
competition
you know even making it into the
semi-final round
is part of a track record that might
help somebody like if the buck stops
here
and i don't know what's going to happen
with the judging you've been doing a
really amazing job and you've
been great i can't speak as to what
possible outcomes will happen but if you
can list participation in this
then another accelerator might be
interested people will see that you have
a track record of
taking this seriously that's data that
is
storytelling that goes on a resume or an
application to something else you're a
member of this competition
um it shows that you are committed to
you know raising funds raising awareness
but also going through a sort of
incubation process
you know more now than you did when you
walked in and that
just puts you already by default in a
better position
for whatever the next opportunity or
competition or
thunder conversation is yeah
100 100 yeah it's exciting i mean that's
the thing
even you know if you win it that's
amazing accolades
great but if you don't you've still done
something
tangible that you can now express as an
outcome
so you know just get into that
storytelling mentality and count
everything because
everything turns into data
one thing i'll say too just as a quick
like thought for your particular case um
if you're looking at like
trying to reach out to these major
fashion brands i think like one thing
that
is really helpful is leaning on the
credibility of somebody
that who has been in the space and so if
you think about either like
i talked about trying to find maybe a
mentor or someone who's done something
really similar
and trying to get both their like data
but also that person can be a really
valuable way to
introduce you to people in the industry
right and you kind of get to like borrow
their credibility
um the other thing that like in your
specific case i think you kind of think
about an order of operations where you
go
and scale like the end users and then
that would help you get in the door with
investors
and then those investors can help make
some of those introductions and also
like
just having names of even like
medium to well-known uh investors is
like
a huge door opener as well so just
something to think about and i'm sure
you're thinking about this stuff but
just
you know kind of that that progression i
think is
um something that's kind of hard to to
gauge at times
yeah well yeah actually we're already
executing on exactly that uh we've been
trying
a couple of things you know to like
build a track record and
kind of uh like hack our way through
to the system right and um one one thing
we've been doing is exactly
what what you're saying we uh reached
out to someone
in la that is running his own custom
custom suit kind of boutique um
and uh you know this this guy
doesn't really know too much about ai
or like you know the fashion tag space
but he has the connections right he's
he's connected to
bands yaga uh even like gucci china and
all of those right
i was like oh wait actually what you're
betting
i love that um like i really do love
that and support that um
here here's the context you know was as
easy as that
that's amazing and networking is another
huge key i mean you build your network
it all starts to fall into place data
storytelling good pitch
good product solid value proposition
right networking
you know these are sort of the steps
that build to the resources
really so yeah oh cool yeah yeah really
exciting times
um yeah we're looking forward to the
same finance and uh
provided hopefully at some point um
and yeah fingers crossed
excited excited to see how everybody
conveys the growth that their ventures
have undertaken in the last few months
how everybody
integrates and applies some of the
feedback from that initial feed
background i mean
i'm getting really excited so um you
know
tell your story and i can't wait to read
it you you have reason to be
exciting times ahead i like it i like
that attitude
very good okay oh well if you have any
other questions let us know either now
or drop us emails and uh
yeah i'll be looking forward to your
submission
cool thank you so much yeah that's
everything from my side um wish wish you
guys
a great evening and uh hopefully talk to
you soon
all right thanks max have a great night